as a working professional it's crucial
to stay competitive in today's
fast-paced business environment one way
of doing that is to upskilling which
refers to the process of acquiring new
skills or enhancing existing ones
bioskilling in areas such as quality
control and lean Six Sigma methodologies
you can contribute to your
organization's continuous Improvement
efforts and help maintain a high level
of quality in their products and
services that is exactly what I did and
I even got a 21 increment in my stipend
as a researcher in my efforts to seek
employment after graduation I also
noticed an increase in the number of
interviews I received and I would
attribute both of these changes to the
knowledge and certification I gained
from seem to learn hi there I'm abdis
and I'm currently seeking a master's
degree in chemical engineering from the
Florida Institute of Technology in
between my undergraduate degree and my
Master's I took training in the lean Six
Sigma expert master's program from
Simply learn and became a green belt my
experience with seem to learn was an
enlightening one the projects were
challenging but gave us the freedom to
apply what we learned in a logical
manner I really did appreciate that the
self-learning courses were in sync with
the live classes this gave me the
opportunity to learn at my own case and
also seek out support whenever I had
questions since completing the program I
have been able to take on newer projects
with much more confidence and perform
way better than before my professional
experience is mostly research focused
where the projects I have taken focus on
improving the design of a product or a
procedure the principles of lean Six
Sigma are widely adopted by
organizations to streamline operations
reduce costs and improve customer
satisfaction by upskilling and lean Six
Sigma you can become a valuable asset to
your organization and contribute to its
success in my downtime I really like to
cook read books and play video games I
recently started going to the gym and
I'm enjoying it a lot if you want to
improve at anything in life Let It Be
Your Fitness or your skills and
knowledge you have to consistently put
in an effort
while a certificate or degree is a hard
record of your achievement it is
ultimately the skills that you gain that
matter which can eventually improve your
performance and output upskilling is no
longer a luxury but a necessity